was war das gestern abend für ein
emotionales ereignis da zitterten die
unterkiefer tränen flossen und unzählige
fische und high fives toten gegeben
nach bangen minuten ist die mars sonde
insight auf dem roten planeten gelandet
und der hammer viele von euch und ich
sind jetzt mit dabei auf unserem
nächsten planeten wie das und was sind
die ersten signale vom länder jetzt den
blick zum science fiction hier gibt's
täglich faszinierend des seins videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts herzlich willkommen ehrlich
gesagt jetzt habe ich gänsehaut ich
gehöre zu den ersten menschen auf dem
mars vielleicht erinnert sich noch der
ein oder andere daran für diesen
siebenmonatigen flug zu unserem nächsten
planeten konnte man sich registrieren
und bekam ein ticket ich hatte damals
den link gepostet wer von euch ist also
gestern auch mit auf dem mars gelandet
schreibt es in die kommentare wie alle
bzw unseren namen sind auf einem
mikrochip an bord der sonde gespeichert
und so sind wir gestern mit erfolgreich
auf dem mars gelandet die erste
erfolgreiche landung seit sechs jahren
und die achte landung überhaupt
herzlichen glückwunsch uns allen das war
wirklich gestern richtig emotional die
spannung war zum zerreißen und nach
zahlreichen zwischen statusmeldungen gab
es schließlich den erfolgreichen
touchdown und wenige minuten später das
erste foto sieben minuten dauerte die
landung nur mit einer geschwindigkeit
von 19.800 kilometern pro stunde tauchte
die sonne in die dünne mars atmosphäre
ein erhitzen sie sich dabei auf 1500
grad celsius und verlor rapide an
geschwindigkeit bis schließlich die
bremsfallschirme gezündet wurden
wie auf der erde haben das alles acht
minuten später erfahren denn so lange
dauert es bis licht vom mars zu uns und
auch jedes andere funksignal bei uns
landet und weitere acht minuten später
kam das erste bild zu uns der mars
horizont ist hinter einer menge an dreck
zu erkennen noch war der staubschutz
nicht entfernt der wurde erst nach
einiger zeit ab gesprengt nachdem sich
der staub der durch die landung
aufgewirbelt worden war gelegt hatte und
so saß dann aus dass die bilder so
schnell zu uns gelangt waren verdanken
wir zwei maß club one satelliten die
daten viel schneller aus dem mars orbit
zur erde senden können
als der mars reconnaissance orbiter über
diese mini satelliten gelangten die
ersten bilder sehr schnell zur erde
gestartet waren diese beiden mini
satelliten zusammen mit dem insight
länder am 5 mai 2018 von der vandenberg
in kalifornien
der insight länder wird sich zum ersten
mal mit einem vom deutschen zentrum für
luft und raumfahrt gebauten schlagbohrer
bis zu fünf metern in den marsboden
bohren dieser maulwurf ist teil des hp 3
experiments an bord dieses sieht flow in
physik properties package soll den
wärmefluss des maß messen und damit
rückschlüsse auf die entwicklung des
mars ermöglichen
professor tilman spohn projektleiter
beim della dazu im prinzip sind das zwar
einfache messungen aber in der
ausführung sind sie kompliziert der
maulwurf des dlr wird temperatursensoren
zentimeter für zentimeter in den mars
boden bringen heizelemente werden dann
den boden aufheizen und sensoren den
wärmefluss messen getestet wurden ließ
unter anderem am dlr institut für
raumfahrtsysteme in einer meter hohen
mit sand gefüllten röhren ein radiometer
am instrument überwacht zudem die
temperatur der oberfläche am landeplatz
aus beiden datensätzen der messung an
der oberfläche und im inneren können die
wissenschaftler wissenschaftlerin dann
auf dem wärmefluss des planeten
schließen zitat aus diesen erkenntnissen
lernen wir dann auch mehr über die
entwicklung unserer erde so professor
spuren eigentlich sollte die mission
schon im märz 2016 starten
doch ein vakuum lag am ersten haupt
experiment dem dem seismometer stoppte
den staat mit ihm sollen erdbeben die
auswirkungen von meteoriten einschlagen
schlägen und sonstige bodenbewegungen
gemessen werden woraus rückschlüsse auf
den aufbau des mars geschlossen werden
können wir können also schon bald
erfahren ob der kern des mars noch
flüssig oder schon fest ist ja wie immer
werde erst hierbei klicks um als erster
erfahren damit ihr kein video verpasst
abonniert am besten auch den englischen
kanal das geht denn auch dort gibt es
immer mehr videopremieren und da drunter
geht es weiter mit mysteriös object
enorm galaxy milky way mystery ich freue
mich auch auf dem englischen
kanal zu tun stay tuned